The next excerpt is
taken from original tape W two thirty
six.
Was
played
on
and so much to go.
But I was thinking about that
last line.
On the grid and with
that
money and money found that I know his pretty well
my
view of the
time
I read it and you heard
her tell
which would she would have been and I think great that was Secretary
Slater Florida.
Yes
I know they had pictures of his
wife but
he's
usually not his
oh you
know when I
was when I went
to
play it.
Came
up to.
And you. Oh no I just I just
more movies
talk about. Your show.
And something. To
you and so this as
well to
let you know.
What I say to
the left.
And from the president. Come They are however possible in that wonderful
and I got a lot. Think of what your grandchildren. Yes I
mean do you believe
you know I said I don't know who still
to be a lesser
wrong. But much of
his life
he
just calls I got
my you know what you know can marry fast or have a telethon.
Would you do if I lost my side of the
law that you have
memory
memory even There's a lot of
memories that I will raise. Yes but
I don't know. And you live through them and I
live and don't lie about what I do
as you said. Power and now from a lot of
your professor that you didn't need your
mother. Know
as
well as tell you I don't go back to that was when I was a girl.
The limits
of my lovers.
He's a Methodist and.
That's
one of these really big
problems when she's led she just
lies.
So is
vacationing going to have
a special treat. Why. But in a
way they were warmly grandpa used to call
the little guy and he
was just setting this thing.
I guess. And he called.
And that's a reason to let you has to learn
to Sunday school and do all the things. Because of your mother and loved her.
So you came from a
background and then the Griffin.
Apparently were well tried on and had money because at least as a headline
Is it also an awful lot of life.
So I don't know what you're
in
Oakland a good try. Why.
I love the fact that
genuinely like the first one I believe what
I remember she was when they
went to. Because somewhere.
Some
are from the mommies and was
really good as
a mother could
be
And
right
from
the.
Real
America.
When
they
came
from the well when you were a child. They came back telling the bastard her different. Body that and then she said. He was apparently killed in Mali married my grandson so that meant probably but had that was a name of that
back
one
lead
list.
We
called.
product that
was a other.
Cover
that period
but I was just curious because I know there was. You wrote in
a
little interestedly. But doesn't thank God
I was playing when you married. If you only
have that on the money tell me how many takes.
And all the things are going
to be sixty. We don't do that now.
Would step for the very very wealthiest where mine was a
Big Wally. You have it to
turn him to try
to trick.
And do you have any idea you have a right upper back waiting.
When
you're
back of the carriage. If you have a first that wedding dress and you have a second a
dress.
Curtain. Struggling with.
I can't sleep.
Now.
He was a burn it later. Yes that's because
Ned Riley. Because
I want you
to have a music in the
church and that is a saying I'll just tell you
where this place
is that
there were
so many of you.
Our memories which you and
many.
I remember going to say
you know I want I was just interested that where our members and how
many take them out of uniform
wearing and then did that they intended you are going honeymoon. Did
you know right away. That's just a myth or
just let it go I don't want to come home
and get it.
And if you have a second they
drag you through room royally
screw you just
do what you're tiny then like you are now. I wish I
knew there and it was a bit of
wind to stand
up
and play to the know what you. Where did they get them from
Colorado from Savannah
and I
just had
a small
little small enough.
But you know you learn different places and you have any of those clothes left.
You know my mother will have part of her wear
the bracelet. She used to make a dress for me when I was going to a party
was the last time I you know.
I don't know.
When
to
leave and I
think I turned it
into something that the
way
so much money tell me about.
One family. From street
of this house is where they
come here where there was kind of a sound.
But she said they made so many take so that when they put them on the front porch.
But I don't never back because when you marry your family we're living now.
But I
was
playing with
his mountain. I hope I don't take that half assed got
a
lot of your presents and
money would show me the place where her mother had
lived which was a lot of magnolias
Leslie and then she told me about the house
on which the first
two story house for the last
three years and that's where they got that obviously
the sound had turned that all the way they
are going to expand. But you know something else I want to talk
about is the best just to
do so.
Yes
it
was cold and yes the power in
America our
way to walk. Young
Jessie you. A room. And he was just.
So
one day and you know you.
Don't
let the.
So the doctor
said we're going to
have that
you
know and
they
also call that I don't know what.
But
anyway yes. Hostile.
Right back up I love
her and.
Jesse show she go buy some.
And
so I just she says. Yes You go
right on that list.
And
says and believe what
a sad to leave
Saudi for the past.
When we come
back why is there
a
question like that
and made us never fall ever
just wanna talk your
legs as if you're looking
like you're in the
tent. After
all but after. The going to come back a
little but you will come back for a stroll.